All right. Good afternoon. My name is Song Yao.
I'm a molecular epidemiologist from Roswell Park Comprehensive
Cancer Center in Buffalo, New York.
It's a great pleasure to be here co-hosting this wonderful
session together with Dr. Kathuri.
So
I'm going to speak for a few minutes, just an introduction to get us
started. And I think we have a wonderful lineup for
seven very
great talks this afternoon. So I have no financial
disclosure.
Cool.
And then-
These are my slides.
Oh, I think those slides changed somehow.
Oh, those are your slides.
Yeah, those are my slides.
Well.
Let me see.
Oh, perfect. Okay.
Thanks for fixing that.
So this is my disclosure.
So for a long time, the traditional
epidemiology, we all know, is all about the associations and then between the
exposure and the disease. But then really,
the
advent of the molecular and genetic epidemiology tries to
fill out the
black box by incorporating biospecimens and then with modern
molecular genetic profiling technologies, we have at our disposal
so many wonderful toys
we can examine to try to understand
the etiology between the
exposure and the risk, and
also for disease outcomes, and
also for response to treatment.
And so there are so many different
aspects of molecular genetic profiling we can
do. We just organize this from DNA to RNA to
protein. And you can see for the human genome itself, we can do
DNA, we can do RNA, and we can do proteins.
And there's so many omics right now that we are all very excited about.
And also, beyond the human genome, we also have
the microbiome. So that's not even the human genome, but then they co-live with
us. This is also a very exciting area.
And then the biospecimen, we can do germline, we can do somatic, and we can do
local, we can do systemic. So there are so many different choices depending
really on the question we have. So to me, this is a really
exciting
discipline, truly the sense of multidisciplinary
area that we have seen huge and huge
growth in the last few decades. So I'm sure we all
are very familiar with the GWAS that have been the dominant
force in the last two decades.
But beyond the GWAS, we now are talking about TWAS,
EWAS, and then also phenotype association
studies, all those large genome-wide
analysis. And also, it's not just the
genome itself, but we're also talking about the spatial
resolution of the different cell components, where they
reside, how they interact with each other.
That opens a whole new dimension of the molecular genetic
epidemiology we are all excited about.
And then some of those is really due to the
advent of the single-cell sequencing, that we have
already started to see
being adapted into population-based sciences.
And all those are very dependent on the
bioinformatics,
that's empowered by the high-performance computing and then cloud-based computing.
So that's really we all know every group
needs a bioinformatician that we have to become good friends with.
And then in order to do this large
science project, we need to have huge sample size.
Sometimes we need even millions of those samples, and all
those have become possible due to the large collaborations
through consortium, through the population-wide biobanks, like UK
Biobank and All of Us project in the US.
But while we are all excited about these newer
technologies, we also need to be mindful of the
incorporation of social and structural environment
consideration in our analysis because those genomics, those
omics, does not occur in a vacuum. It occurs in our society,
and our society has so many different dimensions that have a huge
impact on how the biology works.
And then in addition to that, the population diversity, including
equity, has never become more important these days
than before.
So I hope you all agree with me. The last
decade also has been an incredibly exciting time for molecular genetic epidemiology
research. So that's best exemplified by the seven
wonderful talks we are going to hear today.
So I'm just going to do a one-liner summary for each
project, and then we'll get started from there.
So the first project will be from Dr.
Li
from Vanderbilt, who's going to talk to us about proteomic
signature among former smokers.
And the second project is from Dr. Wang from Harvard, who's going to talk
with us about germline with his early laboratory in shaping the
association of adult height with fatal prostate cancer in the Health
Professional Follow-up Study. And then the third study
will be from Miss Vlasic from
Dartmouth
on ovarian cancer, ovarian tumor copy number
variations inferred from the methylation data.In both
Black and white women.
And then the fourth project is from
Ms. Reid,
from H. Lee Moffitt
Cancer Center, about spatially resolved immune infiltrates in the tumor
and stroma in ovarian cancer in Black women.
And then next is Dr.
Lawson Matro from Fred Hutch, about how
genome sequencing and RNA sequencing about disseminated tumor cells.
About the primary breast tumors in patients with and without
disseminated tumor cells.
And then the sixth project is from
Dr. Wang, another Dr. Wang from Harvard, on the
interaction between colorectal cancer PRS and birth cohorts in
the GECO study. Last but
not least, from Dr. Verma from MSKCC
on the functional characterization of germline variants in
modifying effects of BRCA2 variants.
So I was chatting with Dr. Kachury earlier.
So I generated this word cloud, and as you can
see, the number one word is cancer, apparently.
This is AACR. But other than that, it's very dispersed,
and that really speaks to the
diversity and the versatile molecular genetic epi field
we are working on now.
So just some quick session logistics.
Each presentation will be 10 minutes, followed by five minutes Q&A, and
then Dr. Kachury will deliver a 10-minute closing remarks
at the end.
So without further ado, I would move to Dr.
Li.
Good afternoon. I'm Hui, PhD student at Vanderbilt University.
On behalf of our team today, I would like to present our work on
the plasma proteomic signature for persistent smoking
effects and its association with risk of smoking-related cancer
among former smokers. And before we start, I would like to note
that after receiving the AACR notification for
presentation,
our team keep working and refining our work, and today we would like to
present our latest updated results.
So as you know,
smoking is a leading cause of cancer mortality with
over 30%, particularly lung cancer with
over 80%.
And thanks to the advance of the smoking
cessation program, the number of the
former smokers will double that of the current smokers in the United States.
However, former smokers remain at the higher risk of
the different kind of cancer, particularly lung cancer.
And the previous study indicates that the protein can capture the
biological memory of smoking. But
very few study investigate the long-lasting effects of
smoking among the former smoker.
So this research gap motivate us to conduct this study.
We aim to develop a proteomic signature that reflects the
persistent effects of the smoking, we call the PSPSE
score, after quitting, and evaluate its
association with the risk of smoking-related
cancers among former smokers.
So to address this research question,
we
analyzed over 37,000 UK Biobank
participants who provide the proteomic data and
certify the following exclusion criteria regarding the
smoking history and the low missingness of the proteomic
data. We further excluded the participants who had the cancer
history or who developed the cancer during the follow-up time.
And the final number of the participants
included in our analysis was over
28,000 participants.
We divided these participants into the training and testing sets.
So among the current and never smokers in the training sets,
we conducted the linear regression analysis with its
proteins at outcome and the smoking status as exposure.
We found 1,725 proteins showing
different levels between current and never smokers at the FDR
level less than 0.05.
And using this list of the proteins, we conduct the similar linear
regression analysis among never and former smokers.
And we identify
627 proteins, showing different level between
never and former smokers.
And of these proteins, 177
show persistently different levels between never and
former smokers. And a protein is considered
persistent if they show the different level across different
quitting time windows, including less than 10 year, 10 to
20 years, 20 to 30 years, and over 30 years.
And interestingly, we found 41 proteins persistently
change at least 10% in those who quit from 20 to
30 years or over 30 years compared to never smoker.
And to account for the multicollinearity, we conducted the lasso
regression analysis. After tenfold
cross-validation and 100 repeated times, we identified
18 proteins and used it to develop the proteomic
signature score.
So this figure show us the distribution, the levels of the
proteins included in our signature score.
You can see that all the 18 proteins show in the different level
between former and never smokers across different quitting time
windows.And among the former smokers who quit from 20 to
30 years or over 30 years, their levels
saw at least a 10% change
compared to never smokers.
And the left-hand side figure here shows us the distribution of our signature
score across smoking status. And you can see a clear gradient
here that the current smokers have the highest score, former
smokers were the middle, and never smokers had the lowest score.
And our signature saw very similar discriminative
performance to classify former and never smokers in
either training and test sets.
And
our signature saw a very quick correlation with the years since quit
smoking and moderate correlation with the smoking pack years
among the former smokers, as you can see in these figures.
Using the multivariable cost regression analysis, we found
that our signature shows significant association with the different health
outcomes, including the all-cause mortalities,
COPD incident, smoking-related cancer, particularly
lung cancer, and upper aerodigestive tract cancer.
And when we're conducting the stratified analysis,
we can see that the association between our signature
score and the lung cancer risk
shows the consistent patterns across strata by the site,
age, quitting duration, smoking intensity, and the family history of
lung cancer.
More importantly, we can see that the association remains
significant among the long-term quitters who quit at least 20 years,
and these participants are not eligible to the lung cancer
screening based on the current guideline.
We further evaluate the predictive performance of our
signature.
So as you know, the PLCOM 2012 is a validated
risk prediction model that estimates the six-year risk of
lung cancer.
And the model is mainly based on the self-report information, such
as the demographic, clinical, and detailed smoking history.
And you can see that adding our signature to the PLCOM
2012 models significantly improved the predictive
performance, and the improvement
become largest among the long-term quitters who quit at least
50 years or over 20 years since quit smoking.
We further validate our signature
using the 71 case control nested within the
Shanghai Men's Health Study.
And even though the number of the participants in the validated
cohorts was smaller, and they are all from the
Asian population, but our signatures remain
show the strong association with the increased
risk of lung cancer.
Additionally, when we adjust for the smoking pack year or years since quit
smoking, we still see the significant association.
Excuse me.
So in summary,
we developed a proteomic signature that captures the persistent
effects of smoking, which is associated with your
increased risk of smoking-related cancer or cause
mortality and COPD.
And our signature significantly improved the discriminative
performance of the PLCO models for predicting the lung
cancer risk, particularly among the long-term quitters.
Thank you so much for your attention.
I'm very happy to your question and comments. Thank you.
All right. Thanks very much, Dr Li, for the wonderful talk.
We actually have a little bit more time than five minutes to...
Any questions?
Maybe I will start.
So just wondering if you can share with us about your thought for those
18 proteins you identified, what are their functions, or why you think they are
important and are relevant in this context?
Yes. Thank you so much for your question.
Yes, so, as you can see, we conducted some additional
analysis to see the biological pathway of these
proteins, and this is the supplement results of our
analysis. And we use the
gold,
the library, biomedical libraries for the
different molecular of the different proteins.
And we can see there's some
highlights of the different
molecular function here, such as the cytokine activities
or the G protein-coupled receptor binding
and the growth factor activity as well.
And these proteins show the upregulation
associated with the smoking exposure.
For those proteins that show the negative associated with
the smoking exposure, we can see the other
molecular functions as you can see here.
And based on the literature review, we found
that it's quite consistent, particularly for the cytokine activities
or the growth factor activities, because it's quite popular related
to lung cancer.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Nice talk.
I'm wondering-
I'm sorry. Just wondering if it would be okay to
introduce yourself before asking a question.
Of course.
Thanks.
I don't get to remain anonymous. Okay. So Brock Christensen, Dartmouth.
Nice talk. I'm just curious, there's been some other really nice work from
other groups, um... that have built these
types of predictors using DNA methylation
alterations. I'm wondering if you've done any cross comparison,
and also, second question,
if the persistent proteins that you identify also might be
related to
sort of cumulative dose
of smoking, or intensity,
or duration separately? It's okay if you don't know the answer to the second
question, but I'm wondering if you just look for overlap.
Yes. Thank you so much for your question.
So for your first question related to DNA methylation, and
actually the previous study had indicated that there is 36
CPC sites show the persistently change compared to never smoker,
maybe over 30 years. But because the UK Biobank, they did not
provide
the DNA methylation data, so we did not have the opportunity
to evaluate and to double-check
how the proteins and DNA methylation, what could be the
overlap here. But in the future, we try to find a snow
dataset that can help us to address this quiet question.
For your second question
about
your... Excuse me? Could you-
The intensity or the-
Yeah, intensity. So as you can see- Yeah.
As you can see in our plot here that our signature
scores show the more correlation with the smoking pack year.
So it somehow indicates that it somehow reflects the accumulated
smoking exposure, but it's not very strong
compared to the-- Because it's among the former smoker, not among the
current smoker. So it indicates that
they may change, they may decrease the level, but
at some point they still
remain over the time. Thank you.
So I have a question, if we have time.
Yes.
So you showed a really exciting result showing how the signature
can really improve the performance of the current lung cancer risk
prediction model. Can you maybe talk a little bit about the advantages
of identifying, like for lung cancer screening purposes, what is the
advantage of identifying a proteomic signature of smoking
rather than a proteomic signature of lung cancer directly?
Yes, that's a great question. So previous study, we know
that many group, they developed the proteomic signature for the specific
outcomes, such as lung cancer or the
colorectal cancer or other thing.
But they limited that this kind of signature is not really specific
to the smoking.
Mm-hmm.
And if we develop some kind of signature based on exposure, like the smoking,
we can examine the signature with the multiple outcomes.
And as you can see in our table, we not only focus on the lung cancer, but you can
also see that the signature, so association with all-cause
mortality, COPD, and in the future, if possible, we want to
evaluate the association between our signature with the
type 2 diabetes or the hypertension possibly. Yeah. Thank you.
Any other questions?
All right. Thank you very much, Dr. Li.
Yeah. Thank you.
So I'd like to invite our next speaker to come up, Anqi Wang.
Good afternoon, everyone. Today, I'm very excited to
present our work on the adult height and prostate cancer risk in the
Health Professional Follow-Up Study.
I have nothing to disclose.
So growing evidence has suggested that taller height might be
a risk factor for prostate cancer, especially for
advanced or fatal prostate cancer.
Here on the right, the table summarize results from the pooled
analysis of 15 cohort studies. And you can see that
men of taller height are at a slight increased risk of total
prostate cancer with a borderline significance.
But when we stratify by subtype, the association
is stronger for advanced and fatal prostate cancer
than with localized prostate cancer.
However, the biologic basis underlying this association
remains unclear. So we know that height is
shaped by both genetic factors and early life
exposures, and both of which can influence the risk of prostate
cancer. For example, puberty is a crucial
developmental period
that can
affect both height growth and prostate
growth and development.
So exposure during this period may
have impacts on prostate cancer risk later in life.
So this raises the question whether height in this
context primarily reflect the genetic
factors, early life influences, or a combination of both.
So to address this question, we use the Health Professional Follow-Up Study,
which is a prospective cohort that enrolled more than
51,000 men at baseline. And during follow-up,
a subset of the participants donated their blood or cheek samples
that allowed us to have their DNA information.
And also among men diagnosed with prostate cancer, we were able to
obtain their tumor tissue that allows us to
have their molecular profiling.
So under this rich resource, we conducted three
complementary analysis.
First, in the cohort analysis, with up to 34 year
of follow-up,
we further confirmed the association of height
and prostate cancer risk.
And second, in the genetic decomposition analysis, we try
to separate the genetic from the non-genetic component
of height.And third,
using transcriptomic profiling,
we try to identify molecular features in the tumor that is
also associated with height.
So here shows the results from the cohort analysis.
As expected, we see that taller height is strongly
and positively associated with risk of fatal prostate cancer, but
show little association with total prostate cancer,
which is consistent with previous findings.
And next, we try to separate the
two major contributors to height, the inherited
genetic factors, represented by a whole
genome PRS of height, and the early life nutritional
factors represented by adolescent dairy or milk
intake, which has been previously shown to be a strong
predictor of height.
So here the assumption is both either
components may contribute to height and may therefore, through
certain biologic pathways, increase the risk of fatal prostate cancer.
So here to separate the components, we used a residual approach.
So specifically, we first regressed the observed height
on the height PRS and derived a residual.
So here the residual represents a proportion of height that cannot be
explained by genetics.
We then related this residual factor to fatal prostate
cancer risk and to see how much the association would
be attenuated compared to the total effect of height.
So, here the
rationale is that if the association would
be substantially attenuated, then genetics might
explain most of the observed association with
height. And similarly, we conducted the residual
approach for dairy intake and to compare the
association with fatal prostate cancer and see how much the
association would be attenuated.
So this part of the analysis was led by our master's
student, Diane Fu.
In the genetic residual analysis, we're limited to
participants whose genetic information is available.
And in the subset of cohort, we still see that height
is positively associated with fatal prostate cancer,
although we might be underpowered to detect a significance.
And similarly, we see the PRS of height showed a
similar magnitude of association with fatal prostate cancer,
but the residual of height after accounted for the PRS,
showed essentially no association, which means the
association was largely attenuated after
accounting for the PRS.
And in the dairy residual analysis, again, we saw a
strong positive association for total height.
But after accounting for teenage dairy or milk intake,
the residual of height still showed positive
association with fatal prostate cancer.
So there's little
level of attenuation after accounted for teenage
dairy or milk intake. So taking together the evidence from
both the genetic and dairy residual analysis,
we conclude that here, the association between
height and fatal prostate cancer is mostly likely to be driven
by the genetic components of height.
And next, we turn to the transcriptomic
analysis to identify molecular pathways that may help
explain this association. So here we used microarray gene
expression data in both tumor tissue and paired
adjacent normal tissues. We first
conducted differential gene expression analysis by height
and pathway enrichment analysis across
361 curated gene sets.
So the gene expression analysis was greatly supported by our
undergraduate intern, Michaela.
And at single gene level, we see after multiple
testing correction, no gene remains significant.
But at pathway level, we do see many significant
pathways in tumor and some in normal
tissues.
So here this network map summarize the pathways that are
significant in either tumor or normal tissue, under a
stringent FDR value of 0.05. We found
many interesting pathways here, but today I want to
highlight the androgen response pathway.
So this is both upregulated in tumor and
normal tissue significantly. That means taller height
has higher activity of this pathway, and this is
notable because androgen signaling is thought to play an
important role in both prostate development and prostate
cancer development and progression.
So this might represent one of the pathway linking
height and poor outcomes of prostate cancer.
We also compared the height associated pathways
with those related to either lethal
status or the ERG positivity, which represent a common
molecular subtype of prostate cancer.
So here on the right, we highlight the 10 pathways
that overlap with either ERG or lethal status.
And this is mostlyMarked
by increased translation or
growth-related signaling, and also decreased
apoptosis,
inflammatory signaling, and EMT activity.
So to conclude,
our results confirm previous finding that height is
associated with fatal prostate cancer, and the association is
likely to be driven by the genetics of height.
And also, we were able to identify height-associated
pathways that may also help explain
the poor outcomes among prostate cancer patients.
With that, I would like to acknowledge my mentors,
collaborators, and also my funding sources.
And also, I would be happy to connect about potential faculty
opportunities.
Thank you.
Please come up to the front and ask questions.
Don't be shy.
Hey, Anqi. Great talk. June Chan, UCSF.
I don't know a lot about the genetics of height, so my question just was, are those
scores for the genetics of height independent of race ethnicity?
Or do we know if they're correlated?
Yeah, I think it's a great question.
So, the genetic PRS of height
here,
we used the largest scale GWAS for height, which is
also multi-ancestry GWAS. So, I think
the performance is
great in all populations.
And also, most over... Actually, all of our
genetic population in this study are European ancestry,
which is also the dominant ancestry in the GWAS.
So I think the performance is good.
Hi, Anqi.
Rebecca Kelly, National Cancer Institute.
I just had a quick question about the outcome of lethal prostate cancer
and height.
For adult height, is it correlated with any
potential competing risk of mortality, so the individuals
are more likely or less likely to die from prostate cancer because
of a other risk of death in tall individuals?
Could you-
Yeah. I think it's-
... comment on that?
Yeah.
Thank you.
Great question. I haven't study taller
height on other disease, but I assume that because
a majority of prostate cancer patients die of cardiovascular disease
and other aging-related disease.
But here, we define lethal prostate cancer and fatal prostate cancer as
those died of prostate cancer or have metastasis
during follow-up.
So, I would assume the analysis we see here
is less likely to be impacted by competing risk
of other causes. If there's any, I would
think it would tends to attenuate the association rather than
driving it to this way.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you, Becky.
So, I have a question.
So this is very interesting, and
I'm trying to sort of reconcile the fact that the polygenic score for height,
it's a cumulative summary, and so it doesn't really allow us to
disentangle the biology too much.
But do you think that there's a way in which you can leverage the
information that you're getting from the transcriptomic profiling and the pathways
that come up in that analysis to try to perhaps
decompose
the height polygenic score into some of those sub-components and
then test them individually?
Yeah, I think it's a great question.
I haven't think about linking the height
PRS with the transcriptome profiling,
but I think it is interesting and
promising.
One thing that I also did in this analysis is to look at
single gene association with prostate cancer
risk. Like all the
single level variants associated with height, are they
also associated with prostate cancer risk?
So I think that could be another way that we can try to
interpret this genetic components of height, and their
association with prostate cancer more.
Yeah. No, I think that's great. Yeah.
I guess a
follow-up question is, if we try to disentangle whether the genetics is
sort of the proxy for growth-related biology or hormones
or immune-related factors-
Yeah
... maybe sort of there's a way to do that.
Yeah, agreed. I think there's definitely a lot of more that we can further
explore into more detail.
All right. I have one last question, if you don't mind.
So, do we know, these are the PRS or the
question that you use to assess early dietary factors are not
complete, and they do not explain all the
genetic risks or the dietary risks.
How do you deal with that in your analysis?
Yeah.
I think yeah, it's a great question.
So,
definitely there's,
for example, height PRS showed a great
performance, but it still only explain 50% of the heritability.
Um-But I think
the
results that we see here,
this strong association between height PRS with
fatal prostate cancer risk and the similar magnitude of the association suggests
that height PRS here represents the
genetics of height very well.
And if there's any other components of height
that might be contributed by rarer variants
and other
genetic components that we cannot measure right now, but
those might be, like I said,
rarer. So
as we see here, taller height,
the association is more generalizable to our population.
So I think those common variants may play a more important role
here.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you.
Our next speaker is Irma Wasak from
Dartmouth.
Hello, everyone. My name is Irma Wasak, and I'm a PhD candidate
at Dartmouth.
And I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So high-grade serous ovarian carcinoma, or HSOC, is the most
lethal subtype of ovarian cancer with a five-year survival rate of
41%. This survival rate drops to less than 15%
over 10 years. Unlike many other cancers, it's not
driven by recurrent point mutations, but by widespread copy number
alterations across the genome.
This genomic instability shapes key features of the disease,
including the tumor microenvironment, treatment response, and ultimately
survival outcomes.
So understanding patterns of copy number alteration is critical to
understanding both tumor biology and clinical outcomes in
HSOC.
Over the past several decades, we've seen meaningful improvements in
five-year survival for ovarian cancer, but those gains have not been shared
equally. As you can see here, five-year survival has
steadily increased among White women, reaching around
50% in recent years. In contrast, survival
among Black women has remained relatively flat, staying in the low
40% range.
So despite overall progress, these gains have not been shared equally,
highlighting a persistent and widening disparity where one
group benefits from advances in treatment and care, and another
is largely left behind. This reinforces the need to better understand
both biological and systemic factors contributing to these
inequities.
Building on these disparities, an important question is what's driving them?
While differences in access to care and treatment certainly play a role,
outcome disparities persist even after accounting for these factors,
even among patients receiving guideline-concordant care, suggesting
that this is not the full explanation.
At the same time, our understanding of tumor biology and
HSOC is based largely on cohorts of predominantly
European ancestry, where race and ethnicity are often
under-reported.
This limits both generalizability and our ability to detect
population-specific genomic patterns.
Importantly, self-reported race is not a biological variable.
It reflects social and structural exposures that shape health
outcomes.
So if we want to understand whether tumor biology differs, we need more
precise ways to capture genetic ancestry and integrate that into our
analyses.
Given the high mortality of HSOC and its limited
molecular stratification, this becomes especially
important. In this study, we take an initial step toward that goal
by focusing on tumor genomics, specifically characterizing
copy number alteration-based clusters and evaluating their
associations with survival.
Our study includes 638 patients with high-grade serous ovarian
carcinoma drawn from three large studies.
The African American Cancer Epidemiology Study, or ACES, which is a
population-based case control study focused on ovarian cancer disparities in
African American women. The North Carolina Ovarian Cancer study, or
NCSCS, is a multi-phase population-based case control
study focused on epithelial ovarian cancer in residents of
North Carolina. And the Nurses' Health Study one and two is a
prospective cohort study of female registered nurses.
Importantly, our cohort is relatively diverse, with about
37% self-identifying as Black and 63% as
White.
Across groups, our clinical characteristics of our cohort
are broadly similar, including age at diagnosis and stage distribution,
with the majority of patients presenting with stage three disease.
This provides a well-powered and clinically comparable cohort to evaluate
patterns in copy number alterations and their association with
survival. So we analyzed
638 HSOC tumor samples with matched blood available for a
subset of 296 patients that served as a reference.
DNA was extracted from these samples and profiled using Illumina Epic
methylation arrays. From these data, we infer genome-wide
copy number alterations. We then use these CNA
profiles to perform unsupervised clustering and evaluated
associations with overall survival.
In parallel, we integrated self-reported race to assess differences in
CNA patterns across groups.
Here, we cluster tumors based on genome-wide copy number profiles,
which revealed three distinct copy number alteration
profiles.Starting with cluster one, which
comprises 43.7% of the overall cohort, this
group is dominated by widespread copy number loss across the
genome, resulting in a high fraction of the genome altered,
primarily driven by deletions.
Cluster two represents 39.7% of the overall cohort,
and this cluster is relatively CNA quiet, with most of
the genome remaining copy number neutral.
And lastly, cluster three, which comprises 16.6%
of the overall cohort, shows widespread copy number gains across
many chromosomes.
Together, these clusters defined three major
copy number alteration subtypes: loss dominant, CNA
quiet, and gain dominant tumors.
These patterns are clearly reflected in this heat map, with widespread
deletions in cluster one and broad amplifications in
cluster three, while cluster two remains relatively stable.
We also recapitulate known features of HSOC
biology. For example, the Myc region shows recurrent
amplification, particularly in the gain dominant cluster.
But importantly, our goal is not to just recover known events like Myc
amplification. By defining these clusters, we can start to place these
alterations in a broader genomic context and ask whether these
specific gains and losses are differentially enriched across
subtypes. This allows us to move beyond single events
and begin identifying cluster-specific patterns that may
reflect distinct underlying biology.
Next, we evaluated overall survival across the CNA-based
clusters using the CNA quiet group, C2, as a
reference. While the unadjusted Kaplan-Meier curves are not
statistically significant, the adjusted Cox model
reveals a clearer pattern. Both the loss dominant
cluster, C1, and the gain dominant cluster, C3, are
associated with a higher hazard of death compared to C2, with
C1 reaching statistical significance.
These results are adjusted for key clinical factors, including age,
stage, study, and epithelial proportion.
Overall, this suggests that CNA quiet tumors are associated
with improved survival outcomes.
Next, we asked whether the CNA subtypes might help explain survival
disparities by race. Importantly, cluster membership itself did
not differ by race. However, within the gain dominant cluster,
we observe a significant difference.
Black patients have higher hazard of death compared to white patients after
adjustment. This difference is not observed in the loss dominant or
CNA quiet clusters. Overall, this suggests that disparities
in survival may be concentrated within specific tumor
subtypes rather than uniform across all HSOC.
To better understand the biology underlying these CNA-defined clusters,
we next looked at tumor composition.
Using the same DNA methylation data, we applied HYTIME to deconvolve each
tumor into immune, stromal, endothelial, and epithelial components.
For our downstream analyses, we focus on the epithelial-like fraction,
which captures both tumor and epithelial cells.
This allows us to begin linking the CNA patterns we identified to
differences in underlying tumor biology.
Using the HYTIME deconvolution, we next examined how tumor composition
varies across CNA subtypes. While there is
heterogeneity across tumors, a clear pattern emerges when we
look by cluster.
The CNA quiet group shows significantly higher levels of immune
infiltration, including mononuclear cells, B cells,
natural killer cells, and T cells compared to both the
loss and gain dominant clusters. In contrast, the other
clusters tend to have lower immune infiltration overall.
This suggests that the CNA quiet subtype is characterized by a more
immune-enriched microenvironment, which may help explain its
association with better overall survival.
In summary, we identified three CNA-defined subtypes of
HSOC that capture substantial genomic heterogeneity.
These subtypes are clinically and biologically meaningful.
CNA quiet tumors show increased immune infiltration and improved survival,
while loss and gain dominant tumors are associated with worse outcomes.
Importantly, when we look within subtypes, we find that survival disparities
by race are concentrated in the gain dominant cluster
rather than uniform across all tumors.
Moving forward, we are extending this work by incorporating local
ancestry to better identify ancestry-specific genomic
patterns and by investigating how CNA landscapes shape the
tumor immune microenvironment. Ultimately, this may help
inform more biologically grounded and equitable
approaches to risk stratification and treatment.
With that, I'd like to say thank you, especially to the ACES, NHS, and NCO
CS, and the patients who made this research possible, and thank you to all of my
co-authors and everyone here for taking the time to attend this talk.
With that, I'm happy to take any questions. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Very exciting research.
Thank you.
Questions?
Yes. Nice work. I'm wondering with all of the
CNVs, how did you do baseline adjustment for the ploidy?
Because many times, especially if you have lots of losses,
that ends up getting normalized to
normal. So how did you normalize?
Yes. So this was actually using DNA methylation array data.
Okay.
So we were able to assess any copy number alterations based off
of differences in the shifts of intensity.
And so what we did was for our tumor samples, we used the blood samples as a
reference, and so those will have very little to no copy number
alterations. And then we implemented autocorrection steps as well to
help normalize to the overall baseline to ensure that what we're
actually seeing are copy number alterations, are copy number
alterations, if that answers your question.
Yes. Thank you.
Thank you.
I have a couple questions-
Yes
... if you don't mind.
So I wonder how
reliable it is to infer copy number changes from
methylation data.
Yes.
Because has that been well-established?
Did you do benchmarking?
Yes. So there is current work. So some of the packages we use, such as
CopyNumber, is one of the R packages we use.
There have been research studies showing that they are very comparable and
highly correlated to SNP genotyping-
Okay
... for copy number calling.
One of the caveats is that from the methylation Epic array, we are
perhaps a little bit more limited in the extent of genomic range compared to
genotyping
assays.
However, it is highly correlated.
The copy number calls that are seen in DNA methylation data are
comparable to the ones from genotyping data.
So this has been, yeah, validated previously.
Great.
The next question is,
maybe you have said this, but I missed.
Are there differences in the clusters based on copy number
between Black and White patients?
So in terms of each cluster, we don't see any
necessarily differences in terms of cluster membership by race.
However, when we look at overall survival, we did find that there is a
significant difference between Black and White women in the third cluster.
So that's specifically within that cluster.
And that was the gain dominant, so within a cluster that has a lot of gains.
Thank you. We have a... Yeah, go ahead.
Sure.
Yes.
Paul Sheet, MD Anderson. Thanks. That was a really interesting talk.
Thanks.
I'm a little more used to certain cancers showing chromosome-specific
patterns like you showed with chromosome eight, for example,
and not so much necessarily just genome-wide gains and losses, but
maybe that exists in other cancers as well. So that's one interesting.
Two,
would genome-wide
hypomethylation or hypermethylation ever show up something that
would... Would it ever demonstrate something like in genome-wide gains and
losses, or would they show distinct patterns from
CNAs?
So yes. Are you asking if
any kind of distinct differential methylation that's occurring across a
genome, if that would be
correlated to the copy number alteration that we're seeing?
Yeah. Not correlated so much, but yeah.
Would it look like that ever? I
don't know exactly how you were able to make that distinction
between
large-scale hypermethylation or hypomethylation
and one of the distinct CNAs. I think your findings are robust because the proof is
in the pudding based on what you relate them to afterwards in
terms of the clinical outcomes and so forth.
Yeah. So I think one of the benefits of our approach, which uses specifically
the methylation array data for copy number calling, is that you
can also analyze the methylation data separately because they
are different approaches. So I wouldn't necessarily be able
to assess differential methylation based off of this copy number
calling, but I could have kind of additional analyses focused
on identifying any differential methylation.
I do believe and feel that in this
specific space, that these are distinct.
So I wouldn't necessarily say that a region that shows a lot of
hypermethylation would necessarily be
associated or kind of giving us insight into why we have these regions of copy
number calling.
Thank you.
I'd like to invite our next speaker, Brett Reid.
Good afternoon. I'm Brett Reid from Moffitt Cancer Center, and today I'm going to
be presenting a study that will demonstrate that the spatial context of T cell
infiltration and exhaustion is an important determinant of ovarian
cancer survival in Black women.
As we just heard from Irma, epithelial ovarian cancer is one of the most lethal
gynecologic cancers, with only about half of women
surviving five years post-diagnosis.
And the survival rates and
trends are worse among Black women.
So one of the strongest prognostic factors for ovarian
cancer is the presence of intratumoral T cells, particularly the
CD8 positive cytotoxic T cells.
However, this association varies by race.
So in a prior study, the survival benefit, the
same survival benefit that we saw in White women was not
observed in Black women, even though they had the same
levels of T cell infiltration. And this raises the possibility
that
T cell infiltration alone is not fully capturing the relevant
biology of the tumor immune microenvironment in this population.
So given this, the objective of our study was to more fully
characterize the tumor immune microenvironment in Black
women and identify the phenotypes that are associated with survival.
We focused on two key features: the T cell functional state and the
spatial localization of those T cells.
To characterize function, we assessed the
exhaustion state, which is a state that arises under persistent
antigen exposure
with the upregulation of inhibitory receptors including TIM3 and
PD-1. And these cells exhibit reduced cytotoxic
activity and proliferative capacity.
Now, in parallel, we also characterized the localization of these T cells.
So ovarian tumors have significant tissue heterogeneity
withStromal infiltration throughout the tumor,
and importantly,
where the lymphocytes are located in these regions have shown differences in
their activity, cytokine signaling, and even the transcriptional
programs.
So this supports that these regions
are distinct immune contexts for these cells.
So therefore, our hypothesis was that both the functional state
and the spatial localization of T cells may be more significant determinants of
survival for Black women.
To evaluate this, we utilized whole tissue sections
from primary chemo-naive ovarian tumors, and the
FFPE sections underwent multiplex immunofluorescence, and the
markers included CD3 to identify the T cells,
CD8 to identify cytotoxic T cells, and then for
exhaustion, we included the inhibitory receptors TIM-3 and PD-1.
Spatial localization was quantified using a compartmental approach,
where cell coordinates were used to generate smooth point pattern
intensities for the tumor and stroma.
And we then excluded the mixed interface regions.
And this resulted in more homogeneous, spatially resolved
tumor and stroma compartments for our analysis.
The resulting measures included compartment-specific T cell and subpopulation
proportions, which were analyzed using Cox proportional hazards
regression. And to build the models, we used a hierarchical modeling
approach where we decomposed the immune response into
three biologically distinct components.
So first, we modeled a term for the extent of T cell infiltration,
which was the ratio of CD3 positive to CD3
negative
proportions.
Okay. And then next, we modeled the composition
of the T cells,
the cytotoxic composition of the T cells.
So this was
the CD8 positive to CD8 negative ratio in the
CD3 positive cells. And this term captures the cytotoxic
enrichment that is independent of the total T cell
abundance.
And third, we modeled the exhaustion within cytotoxic T cells using the
TIM-3 positive to negative ratio in the subpopulation
of CD3 positive and CD8 negative cells.
And again, this captures the exhaustion effect that is independent of
both the cytotoxic composition and also the total T
cell abundance. And so together, this model allows us to
distinguish if survival
is driven by how many T cells are present, what type they
are, and whether they're functionally engaged all in the same model.
And our models were adjusted for batch and clinical factors.
In total, there were 221 Black women from the ACES
study that were included in our analysis, and most
had high-grade serous subtype and were of advanced stage
disease.
The whole tissue sections, half
of the samples had one million or more cells, and
this is exponentially larger than, say, the tissue microarray cores that
we've more typically seen in these studies, which have 5,000 to 10,000 cells on
average. So it's much larger.
In the
tumor region, the
median T cell proportion was
2% or higher, and this was two times higher in the stroma regions.
Now, of these T cells, 30% in the tumor region were
cytotoxic, and of the cytotoxic T
cells, 3% had the TIM-3 marker, and less than
1% co-expressed both the TIM-3 and PD-1 marker.
And these
exhausted and cytotoxic proportions were slightly
lower in the stroma regions.
And when we modeled the immune features for the tumor and stroma separately using
stratified models, we didn't see any significant associations with survival.
However, when they were both modeled together in a combined model, we then see that
higher cytotoxic T cells in
the tumor are associated with better survival, whereas when in
the stroma, they're associated with worse survival.
So given these opposing effects, we next looked at the difference between the
cytotoxic T cell enrichment in the tumor and stroma using a
gradient metric.
And we found that this metric was associated with survival, where if
cytotoxic T cell enrichment in the tumor was higher relevant to the
stroma, we see better survival.
And another way to look at this that may be a little more intuitive is to
categorize this gradient into whether the cytotoxic T cells are higher in
the tumor versus in the stroma. And so looking at this
distribution of the gradient metric, we used a one and a half fold
threshold where tumor stroma
cytotoxic T cell enrichments that were within 50%
of each other were classified as equivalent.
Whereas if it was 50% higher or more in the tumor, it was
tumor dominant, and then vice versa for the stroma, being
stroma dominant.
And we see that 50% of tumors were tumor dominant.
When we looked at survival in these groups, we see that the
tumor-dominant cytotoxic T cell enrichment is associated with better
survival.
Now, a
helpful exercise is to visualize these immunotypes
across different T cell localization patterns.
So here I have
three samples, and in the first sample where T cells are
confined to the stroma region, in standard terminology, we would typically call
this immune excluded, whereas the other two would be immune infiltrated.
However, using our gradient immunotypes I just described, this would be a
stroma-dominant tumor, this would be equivalent, and this would be
tumor-dominant. And based on our survival results, we see that the
stroma-dominant and the equivalent
tumorsare more likely to have a higher likelihood
of mortality.
And this differs a bit from the abundance framework where
immune-infiltrated would be prioritized as having better survival over the
immune-excluded.
Another key distinction that we can see here in this other example is
that even in the presence of tumor infiltration, we can
still have pretty significant stroma dominance.
So
here we look at tumors that have at least
2% T cell infiltration, and we see
that
50%
would be classified as either equivalent or stroma dominant, and those would
have worse survival.
Now, here I want to circle back to T cell exhaustion.
So in our primary models, we did not see an effect of exhaustion with
survival overall. However, to have T cell exhaustion, it's
conditional on the fact that you have, in fact, T cell infiltration.
And so we also wanted to determine whether, given in the presence of T cell
infiltration, if those tumors have any survival
differences based on exhaustion.
And so here we restricted our models to tumors that had at least 2% T cells
present in their tumors.
And also specifically here, I limit to the high-grade serous subtype, which also
has higher T cell infiltration than other subtypes.
And in this subset, we see that tumor exhaustion is associated with better
survival.
And additionally, I'd also like to point out that this effect of tumor
exhaustion did not vary by the levels of stroma exhaustion, and so
that differs from what we just saw with the cytotoxic T cell
enrichment effect.
So in conclusion,
we found that cytotoxic T cells had
opposing survival effects based on their localization.
And we
were able to effectively summarize this in a gradient metric
where
tumor-dominant cytotoxic T cells were associated with better
survival. And we also found that tumor-specific T cell exhaustion
was associated with improved survival.
And these features may reflect that there's higher effector response and
antitumor immunity in these patients.
So now with this study, we've identified immune phenotypes that are prognostic in
Black women, and we are now framing future work to evaluate whether
these features vary across the racial groups and whether they may
contribute to the differences that we see in survival outcomes.
And additionally, I'd just like to point out that we should continue to
refine
these phenotypes, and particularly we're moving forward to looking
at spatial clustering in these compartments, as well the dynamics of the tumor
stroma interface region and whether they may relate to survival.
And with that, I'd like to acknowledge the internal and external collaborators that
contributed to this research from the Perez Lab, and thank you for your
attention.
We have time for at least one question.
Any questions from the audience?
Okay. Well, if not, then maybe I'll ask one question to
maybe get things started. So given these really interesting sort of and
complex context-specific effects that you've uncovered, can you talk a little bit
about some of the limitations with reliance on more
traditional tissue microarrays and maybe some of
the information that we might be missing
in those types of studies, and whether we should really be thinking about how to
enable more spatial profiling in population-based studies?
Yeah. So given these results, at least in this population, I think we're
missing the larger picture, which is actually more important for their survival,
right? So using the whole tissue sections, we're able to see,
especially in that example that I showed, where we can see tumor
infiltration, and certainly if a core was taken there, we would classify that tumor
as infiltrated. And I think it's this misclassification that may
be bringing us to the null with this population.
I'm not sure if I can infer that to the
trends that we see in white women. That's obviously a
future goal.
But
yes, I have looked quite a bit into the tissue microarrays
and the
correlations across multiple areas.
And again, this is largely in a population of white
women. So,
they have high correlation across three, six, 12
different cores in the tumor. But again, it seems like we're not really capturing
the heterogeneity, and whole tissue sections do that a little better, is what
we're seeing here in terms of the tumor stroma context.
Thank you.
Hi. Amazing talk. So much great work.
Gemma, Jovi-Bray Women's Hospital.
I was wondering if you could comment now on after you've
established the associations of these, we'll say, immune phenotypes,
what that could look like potentially in different actual
histotypes.
If you expect to see similar associations across histotypes, or there's something
that just might be more driven by high-grade serous knowing that that's where your
budget is.
Yeah. So we had multiple histotypes in this study.
Obviously, most was high-grade serous.
Even though we had small sample size, we did look across the other histotypes.
We had some good endometrioid,
for example, sample size. And we do see similar trends in
those histotypes. Obviously, particularly for exhaustion, which is
why I limited to the high-grade serous, where it's dependent on having a high level
of infiltration. I think exhaustion would be more important there
for that histotype. But even though we weren't well-powered, we
didn't see any differences byhistotype.
So I think that's something definitely to look into moving
forward and try to get the sample sizes that we need to determine that.
Okay. Well, let's thank our
speaker one more time.
Thank you.
Next, Dr. Kayli Lawson-Micho.
Good afternoon.
All right. My name is Kayli Lawson-Micho.
I'm a postdoctoral research fellow at Fred Hutch Cancer Center,
and today I'll be presenting on biologic processes enriched in the primary
tumor of invasive breast cancer patients with disseminated tumor cells.
Sorry, I want to share with my slides. I'm hoping to fix.
This is not your slide.
Can we get presenter mode?
What?
Is there a way we can show it in presenter mode?
Is there a way we could put the slides in presenter mode?
No.
With the notes.
The presenter mode with notes.
No?
That's okay. And that's okay. I
think. I'm not sure if they have to do that. Do you have your computer?
Do you know what the next-
That's okay. I'll move forward with it as is. Yeah.
All right.
Again, I'll be presenting on biologic processes enriched in the primary
tumor of invasive breast cancer patients with disseminated tumor cells.
I have no relevant financial disclosures.
Despite major advances in early
detection and treatment, distant recurrence remains a leading cause of breast
cancer-related mortality.
Hormone receptor-positive breast cancer, the most common subtype, which accounts
for approximately two-thirds of cases, is usually diagnosed at an early
stage when survival is high.
However, even among hormone receptor-positive breast cancer patients
treated up to five years on endocrine therapy,
10% of node-negative and 30% of node-positive patients will
reoccur by 10 years. And unlike hormone receptor-negative breast
cancer, which is unlikely to recur after five years.
Unlike hormone receptor-negative breast cancer, which is unlikely to recur after
five years, hormone receptor-positive breast cancer patients recur at a
steady rate up to 20 years after diagnosis.
And at 20 years, the cumulative risk of distant recurrence is
22% among node-negative and close to 50% among
node-positive patients. And once a distant recurrence
occurs, five-year survival drops to 30%.
Thus, there's an urgent need to intervene before overt metastatic disease
presents.
Disseminated tumor cells are hypothesized to be the cause of distant
recurrence. These cells are particularly important in these late
recurrences because once they've disseminated and settled in the distant
tissue, they can remain dormant for years or decades before progressing to
overt metastatic disease.
Disseminated tumor cells have been detected in the bone marrow for approximately
35% of early-stage breast cancer patients.
And while their presence is associated with a fivefold greater risk of distant
recurrence, two-thirds of DTC-positive patients will not reoccur.
This suggests that
eliminating
DTCs with high metastatic potential could substantially improve
survival. However, no targeted therapies currently exist.
There's two major barriers to developing targeted therapies for DTCs, and
that's pathways have not been fully characterized in human populations.
In detection, bone marrow aspiration followed by specialized assays
is invasive and cannot distinguish patients with DTCs that are primed for
metastatic recurrence from those with low metastatic potential.
Thus, our research objective was to identify the features of the primary
tumor that are associated with dissemination and distant recurrence.
And the potential impact of this is to try and identify patients that are at a high
risk of recurrence.
Yeah. So the potential impact of this work is to identify patients that are at a
high risk of recurrence.
So to identify features of the primary tumor associated with
dissemination and distant recurrence, we're using a unique prospective
cohort of invasive breast cancer patients who do
not have clinically detectable metastatic disease at the time of diagnosis,
but who have undergone
bone marrow biopsy for direct assessment of DTCs at the
time of diagnosis.
This is an actively recruiting cohort, and so far we've sequenced
148 participants who have RNA-seq, whole genome sequencing, and
direct assessment of DTCs.
The baseline characteristics of the participants included in the present analysis
are shown here.
Our cohort is majority early-stage hormone receptor-positive breast cancer
patients, which includes luminal
A and luminal B.And we observed that
DTC positive tumors were more likely than DTC negative
tumors... Or we observed that in our cohort, DTC
positive patients were slightly older than DTC negative patients.
However, this difference was not statistically significant.
So using the tumor normal whole genome sequencing, we looked at the prevalence of
somatic mutations in major breast cancer genes overall and
separately within DTC positive and DTC negative patients.
In the overall cohort, we observed that the prevalence was similar to that
reported in TCGA and other large breast
cancer cohorts.
While the difference of certain driver genes did differ by DTC status,
none of these differences were statistically significant after FDR
correction.
However, when we looked at the prevalence of somatic mutations in
major breast cancer pathways rather than in individual genes,
we observed that DTC positive
patients compared to DTC negative patients
were more likely to have a somatic mutation in one or more genes
involved in the Wnt/β-catenin pathway, which is important for cell fate
determination. The PI3
kinase/AKT/mTOR pathway, which is important
for proliferation, cell growth,
and survival, as well as the
NRF2 pathway, which is
an oxidative stress response pathway.
Using the whole genome sequencing data, we also looked at mutational signatures,
which are patterns of somatic mutations that reflect prior exogenous and
endogenous exposures.
We observed that while the prevalence of mutational signatures did not
differ overall by DTC status, DTC positive
patients had a close to twofold
increase in the activity of APOBEC mutagenesis.
And this is important because APOBEC mutagenesis has been shown to increase in
metastatic disease, and also drives subclonal diversity,
which can lead to increased treatment resistance.
To assess whether pathways with increased mutational burden in DTC positive
patients had functional consequences at the transcriptomic level,
we performed gene set enrichment analysis using the bulk RNA sequencing
data from the same primary tumors and evaluated differential
pathway activity between mutated and wild type tumors.
Pathways are shown on the Y-axis, and the normalized enrichment score for a
particular pathway is shown on the X-axis, with increased activity shown to
the right and decreased activity shown to the left.
The color corresponds to the location of the pathway relative
to, an example, Wnt in this case, and the size of the
bubble corresponds to the number of genes in the pathway.
We observed that Wnt mutated DTC positive tumors had an
increase in epithelial mesenchymal transition signaling.
And this pathway is important in which could lead to
migration, invasion, and increased survival at distant sites.
Conversely, these tumors also showed downregulation of proliferative pathways,
and taken together, these findings suggest that Wnt mutations in
DTC positive tumors are shifting the transcriptional state of the
tumor away from proliferation and towards a dedifferentiated
mesenchymal-like program.
In contrast, PI3 kinase mutated tumors showed broad
transcriptional upregulation of proliferative pathways.
The one exception to upregulation of downstream pathways was
apoptosis.
And this suggests that these tumors are increasing
proliferation without regulating cell death.
And importantly, in our cohort, we observed that this was independent of estrogen
receptor signaling, which could indicate that these patients have
an increased propensity for endocrine therapy resistance.
So in summary, we observed that in our cohort, breast cancer patients with
disseminated tumor cells in the bone marrow at the time of diagnosis
were characterized not by single driver genes, but rather
by somatic mutations in
major breast cancer pathways, including Wnt, PI3 kinase,
and NRF2.
We observed that for DTC positive patients with somatic mutations in the
Wnt pathway,
had an increase in epithelial mesenchymal transition signaling,
and a decrease in proliferative signaling, which is consistent with a stem-like
migratory phenotype that might be primed for dissemination and survival in the bone
marrow.
For somatic mutations in the
PI3/AKT/mTOR pathway, we observed that
these were associated with an increase in
proliferative pathway expression,
and a decrease in apoptosis.
We also observed increased APOBEC mutagenesis.
And this suggests that there's really likely multiple interrelated pathways that
are driving dissemination. It's going to depend on the timing of dissemination as
well as the specific subtype that we're looking at.
But these preliminary results may suggest that APOBEC mutagenesis,
Wnt pathway mutations,
PI3 kinase pathway mutations, as well as NRF2
may be potential biomarkers for high-risk patients.
This is largely hypothesis-generating given our limited sample
size.And now I'm going to briefly talk about next steps
and future directions. So these were results from preliminary
analyses. We're continuing sequencing efforts to increase our sample
size to 700 by the end of 2026.
We're evaluating the functional relevance of pathways with decreased
mutational burden to see if these pathways may be driven by
cell-intrinsic factors or the tumor immune
microenvironment. We're also using
single-cell deconvolution and spatial transcriptomics to distinguish tumor
intrinsic from tumor microenvironmental and extrinsic factors.
We're currently building TMAs for
validation of some of the markers and the pathways identified today.
And then ultimately, since the
clinical relevance of these findings really depends on not only if
these molecular features are associated with the presence of disseminated
tumor cells at the time of diagnosis, but if they're also associated with
distant recurrence. And so this is an actively recruiting cohort.
We won't have long-term follow-up for a lot of these ER-positive breast cancer
patients. We may not observe recurrence for a lot of these
ER-positive breast cancer patients until 10 to 15 to 20 years.
So we're going to be leveraging a complementary cohort, which has molecular
data that was sequenced in the same lab and has
long-term follow-up data through EHR linkages up to 15 years
after diagnosis.
I just want to say a huge thank you to my primary mentor, Dr.
Chris Lee, and everybody involved in our research team.
The Gehar Lab at Fred Hutch does all of the single-cell sequencing for our DTCs,
and it's an immense amount of work.
So I just want to recognize everybody involved, and I'm not going to end with
questions quite yet. I just want to share an advocate
perspective. As part of our study, we work really closely with patient advocates,
and one of the patient advocates, Debbie, who we worked with,
provided some thoughts on these results.
And what she really emphasized was that
it's really important to ensure cancers with high risk of recurrence receive
appropriate therapy, but also
important to ensure that we're sparing patients with lower risk cancers, the
toxicities of treatment that they would offer no additional benefit.
That's really where risk stratification comes into play.
And then I'll open up for questions with whatever time we have left.
Sorry about the technical difficulties.
Yes, thanks very much. Very cool and unique study.
I think we have time for one question.
Hi. Sabina Kasimbauer from Germany.
We're also working on DTCs, and my question is, how do you detect the cells
and how many
bone marrow cells do you evaluate to detect these cells?
And when is a patient positive?
Yeah, that's a great question. So that's being performed by the Gehar Lab, and
they're using single-cell sequencing.
So they take the bone marrow aspirate,
and they have a
single-cell sequencing technique.
I'm not as familiar with the actual technical
aspects of it, but I have the paper that I can send to you as a reference.
But essentially, one of the first steps is detecting things like EpCAM
markers. Well, actually, the first step, I think, is removing a lot of the
fat and tissue that they don't want from the bone marrow aspirate.
Then after that,
to actually detect the DTCs amongst all of the other
osteocytes and other cells that you would find in the bone marrow.
The first marker that they're using is EpCAM.
After that, this
is something they've been working on for the last three years and adjusting over
time to identify other markers of DTCs.
And
I can send you the paper that has more-
Yeah, that would be great.
-technical information on it. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Yep.
I'd like to invite our next speaker, Xinyu
Wang.
So good afternoon, everyone. I'm Xinyu Wang.
I'm a master's student from Department of Epidemiology, Harvard Chan School of
Public Health. It's my great honor to be here today to present our
project titled "Germline Genetic Impact on Risk of Colorectal
Cancer According to Birth Cohort."
First of all, I have no financial relationships to disclose.
Colorectal cancer is the third most commonly diagnosed cancer and the
second leading cause of cancer-related deaths worldwide.
Over the past few decades, there have been distinct trends in CRC
incidence according to age. In contrast to a slight
decrease among people aged 50 years or above, there is
a rapid increasing trend for early-onset CRC.
Although the underlying cause of early-onset CRC remain largely unclear,
birth cohort effect is believed to play a very important role, given
the observation that the increasing trend of CRC
incidence is primarily observed among people born after
1950s or 1960s. Individuals born in more
recent birth cohorts have a very different exposure history
compared to those born in the earlier cohorts, characterized by
an epidemic of obesity, particularly childhood obesity,
increasing prevalence of sedentary behavior and ultra-processed food
intake, as well as higher pollution and environmental chemicals.
So this suggests that birth cohort may serve as a broad,
great proxy for us to capture composite and cumulative
lifetime exposure history.In addition to
environmental risk factors, genetic factors are also playing very
important roles in colorectal carcinogenesis, and the genetic
effects might be modified by environmental exposure, together
forming the notion of gene environmental interaction in colorectal
cancer. A previous study reported that a polygenic risk
score of CRC was more strongly associated with early
onset compared to late onset CRC. However, simply
stratifying by age at diagnosis may not be adequate to
capture the underlying biology of early onset CRC,
since individuals diagnosed at the same age may come from
different birth cohorts and may therefore have been exposed to
very different environmental risk factors.
Therefore, we aimed to further examine the association between
PRS and CRC across different birth cohorts, and we
specifically hypothesized that the CRC PRS
is more strongly associated with colorectal cancer risk in the more
recent than remote birth cohort, reflecting the interaction
between genetic susceptibility and the changing environmental
landscapes.
So the current study used data from two main sources.
One is Genetics and Epidemiology of Colorectal Cancer Consortium,
GEcco, which is a large international collaboration that
included well-characterized case control studies and cohort
studies conducted in North America and Europe.
The other is UK Biobank, which is a well-known large
prospective cohort study. And by putting these two studies together,
we managed to get more than 31,000 cases and more than
52,000 controls. And down below, we show the
distribution of our participants across different birth cohorts, and we
can see that most of our participants are born between
1920 to 1960.
For statistical analysis, we calculated the polygenic
risk score of CRC by the weighted sum of risk alleles
across 204 autosomal genetic variants reported by the
most recent and the largest CRC GWAS, which together
explained nearly 20% of familiar risk of
CRC. We used logistical regression to assess the
association between PRS and CRC by birth cohort,
adjusted for sex, genotyping platform, study, and top 10
genetic principal components to account for population stratification.
All the analysis were conducted in GEcco and UK Biobank
separately, and we meta-analyzed the results using fixed effects
models. To assess whether the birth cohort effect of
PRS differ by subgroups, we further performed the subgroup
analysis by age at diagnosis, history of screening,
family history of CRC, as well as CRC subsites and
molecular features. To better understand the underlying
mechanisms, we performed a pathway analysis by first
examining the interaction between individual SNPs
comprising the CRC PRS and birth year in relation to
CRC. We performed a downstream functional annotation and
conducted a gene set enrichment analysis, as well as
overrepresentation analysis to assess whether the genetic
variants that show a stronger birth cohort are enriched in
specific biological pathways.
So here is the overview of our study results.
In Panel A, we show that the distribution of PRS did not
differ significantly by birth cohort.
So this suggests that the prevalence of genetic risk factors
itself did not change significantly across
generations. In Panel B, we show that the association
between PRS and CRC is generally increasing in more recent
birth cohorts compared to earlier ones, with a P value for
trend less than 0.001.
When we examine the association by subgroups, first
by age at diagnosis, we primarily observe the birth cohort
effect of PRS among those younger than 55
years old, as indicated by the red line here.
In contrast, the magnitude of association is slightly
decreasing among people older than 75 years old, as
indicated by the green line here. And in Panel B, by
history of screening, we consistently observed a stronger
association between PRS and CRC among unscreened
individuals compared to screened ones.
Consistently, we primarily observed the birth cohort effect of
CRC among those without a family history
of CRC, as indicated by the
blue line here, which may also due to the effect of screening,
since participants with a family history of CRC tend
to engage more in screening practices.
And again, the association between PRS and CRC is
attenuated among screened individuals.
And when we assess the CRC subtypes,
we primarily observe the birth cohort effect of PRS for distal
colon cancers and rectal cancers compared
to proximal colon cancers. This is also consistent
with the observation that the rising incidence of early onset CRC
is primarily observed for these two cancer sites rather than
proximal colon cancers. And we did not observe
significant birth cohort trend by molecular subtypes,
but only around 20% of CRC cases in our
study have molecular data, which might limit our statistical
power.
In gene set enrichment analysis, we identify the innate immune
system as the top enriched pathway, which might
explain the underlying mechanism of the birth cohort effect
of PRS in relation to CRC. And we also
get very similar results using overrepresentation
analysis.The strength of the current study
includes the large sample size, which enable us to detail the
evaluated PRS associated CRC risk across different
birth cohorts, both overall and within the subgroups.
And we did centralized harmonization of phenotype and genotype
data across different studies, which help us to reduce
bias and increase the generalizability.
However, there are also some limitations.
For example, we did not consider high penetrance pathogenic
variants, such as those associated with Lynch syndrome and other
hereditary cancer syndromes. And we have only
a relatively small number of cases for those born
before 1920 or after 1960. And
because our analysis are all performed among individuals of
genetically defined European ancestry, our findings may not be
generalizable to populations of non-European ancestry, and
future studies are warranted to identify whether there is a
similar birth cohort effect in other populations.
In conclusion, we found that the association between PRS and
CRC risk was stronger in more recent compared to earlier birth
cohorts. And, um, the birth cohort effect show PRS
is the most pronounced among those without a
family history of CRC and also for distal colon cancers
and rectal cancers compared to proximal colon cancers.
And our findings implicate the role of gene environmental
interaction in the rise in early onset CRC and
highlight the increasing utility of genetic risk stratification
in the contemporary population. And we call for future studies
to better understand the underlying mechanism of the birth cohort
effect, as well as the underlying biology of the early onset
CRC.
With that, I would like to thank my advisor, Dr. Mian Song, and Dr.
Ricky Peters from the Fred Hutch Center for their tremendous
support and guidance throughout this project.
I'd also like to thank all the consortium members from GECCO and all the lab
members from the Song Lab at the Harvard Chan School of Public Health.
And thank you very much for your attention.
I'm happy to take any comments or questions.
I'd like to encourage our audience members to come up to the
microphone and ask any questions.
Okay, in the meantime,
I'll start with a question. I think
this is a big one, and I'm not actually even
sort of sure how you would maybe go about teasing this apart.
But what are your thoughts on
how do we disentangle true gene environment interactions just
from other things that are correlated with birth cohorts?
Changes you mentioned in screening, diagnostic practices.
What are your thoughts on that?
Yeah, thank you. That is a really great question, and I think that's the very
essence why we are performing subgroup analysis both by age at
diagnosis and screening. For example, for screening, we
observe stronger association between PRS and CRC among
unscreened individuals. And one
possible reason is that unscreened
CRC cases may better represent the natural
history of CRC, while for those screened individuals,
the controls may have undergone colonoscopy and they
might already have colorectal polyps
removed. So without
screening, they might develop into cases.
So that screening kind of attenuated
the contrast between cases and controls, and that's why we observe
a weaker association between PRS and CRC among
screened ones. Yeah.
Have you looked at the birth cohort composition of
the PRS training data? That's
probably a GWAS meta-analysis with-
Yeah
... a lot of different studies.
Yeah.
But do you sort of have a sense of maybe which birth cohorts might be
overrepresented in that training set?
Actually, I think,
like, some of the data for that GWAS also come from
GECCO.
Mm-hmm.
So I think there is kind of an overlap between birth
cohorts. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, I guess what I'm trying to get at is maybe if the training data are
skewed towards a particular-
Yeah
... population, then that could maybe contribute.
Mm-hmm.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Any other questions?
All right. Thank you very much.
Our last speaker for the talk today, Dr.
Verma from MSKCC.
Good afternoon. I'm Shiv Prakash Verma from Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center.
Today, I do not have any financial interests to disclose here.
Today, I will be talking about study 13 and LATTEs 2 exists,
which may act as a BRCA2 modifier in breast cancer.
So pathogenic variants in BRCA2 are well-known to increase breast
cancer risk, which is known to vary among carriers.
Some individuals develop cancer early, while others remain unaffected throughout
their life, indicating substantial variability in penetrance.
This graph shows the penetrance of breast cancer in BRCA2 carriers.
This heterogeneity suggests that additional factors, particularly genetic
modifiers, play an important role in shaping disease risk.
Genome-wide association studies and functional analysis have identified
multiple modifier loci, pointing towards pathways involved in
DNA repair, cell cycle control, and signaling
networks.In this context, we focused on identifying and
characterizing novel modifier pathways that may influence
BRCA2-associated breast cancer risk.
So candidate causal variants for the over 300 breast cancer
SNPs to be expanded to over 500 SNPs at the
conference presentation at this meeting, with many of these studied
by fine mapping and functional annotation that will not be summarized
here. Here we cite a particular effort that combined
BCAC, SIMBA, and other breast cancer genetic epidemiology
consortiums deriving a case-specific analysis.
Among 5,000 BRCA2 mutation carriers, they identified
multiple risk-associated loci, including a region containing
STARD13 as a potential modifier. STARD13 is a
tumor-suppressive ROCAP that dampens rho family signaling,
thereby regulating actin organization, focal adhesion turnover,
cell movement, and proliferative behavior.
In breast cancer, loss or downregulation of STARD13 is
associated with great motility, EMT-like behavior, and
pro-oncogenic signaling, such as Yap/Taz activation.
Because of somatic role of STARD13 in BRCA2 cancer, we were
interested in studying its functional determinants as a genetic modifier
of BRCA2 in breast cancer. To address this, we first
needed a relevant model system.
After looking at limitations of existing cell lines, we generated
BRCA2 6174delT mutant MCF10A cell line
carrying heterozygous truncating mutations that introduce a premature
stop codon, leading to BRCA2 protein truncation.
These clones were validated using multiple approaches.
Sanger sequencing, that is Figure A, confirmed the presence of
intended heterozygous mutation.
We observed around 50% reduction in BRCA2 transcript levels in
MCF10A cells, that is Figure B,
consistent with a heterozygous loss of function state and prior reports.
This system provides a platform to study modifiers of BRCA2-associated breast
cancer biology.
This slide summarizes our overall strategy to study STARD13 as a
potential BRCA2 modifier using two complementary arms,
an in silico variant to function track, and a cell-based functional
perturbation track. First, we took a GWAS to locus
driver approach.
We followed the association signal at the STARD13 locus, prioritized
non-coding candidate variants, and then tested whether those
variants have regulatory activity.
Second, we took a gene-centered functional approach.
We targeted the STARD13 transcript directly using knockdown and
profiled the downstream effects.
Critically, we did these perturbation experiments in parallel with and
without BRCA2 mutation to ask whether the impact of STARD13
depends on BRCA2 status.
In our first approach, we used FPS and AlphaGenome
to prioritize SNPs. The functional potential score, or FPS,
is a pipeline developed by our colleagues at Sloan Kettering, Dr. Boas.
It is designed to prioritize GWAS loci and candidate risk variants for experimental
follow-up. This pipeline systematically integrates driver functional
annotation from multiple resources and summarizes them into a
single score that reflects the relative functional potential of each
variant.
So looking at the STARD13 locus identified in the prior BCAC
and SIMBA study, our initial goal was to prioritize the functionally more
relevant SNPs using the FPS and other predictive algorithms.
Among the candidate variants at this locus,
RS3742324 stood out as it maps to
a region characterized by open chromatin,
enhancer-associated histone modifications, and transcription
factor binding in human breast tumors and mammary epithelial cells.
It also had the highest functional potential score, making it a
strong candidate for further functional evaluation.
This is a UCSC browser plot showing attacks set from TCGA
breast tumor, DNA's high sensitivity, enhancer marks, and
transcription factor binding region around the prioritized SNP.
After prioritization, we wanted to evaluate the effect of SNP
RS3742324 on potential enhancer activity
of this region and determine if STARD13 was regulated by this putative
enhancer. To address this, we performed two experiments.
First, we used a luciferase reporter assay to
evaluate a 500 base pair region spanning the prioritized variant,
which revealed allelic
difference in enhancer activity.
Second, we performed qPCR following CRISPR-mediated deletion
of an 800 base pair region containing the SNP, which resulted in
downregulation of STARD13 expression.
Figure A shows the green region labeled CER, which is used for the luciferase
assay, and the gray region, labeled DEL, which is used for CRISPR-mediated
deletion. The luciferase assay indicates that region
spanning the selected SNP exhibits allele-specific enhancer
activity as shown in Figure B.
This region functions as an enhancer regulating STARD13 as shown in Figure
C,
where CRISPR deletion of the enhancer leads to downregulation of STARD13.
To explore an alternate method for variant prioritization, we employed
AlphaGenome, a new Google DeepMind AI model
that predicts the functional impact of DNA variations.
Based on AlphaGenome, we selected three highly ranked variants for
functional testing, shown in light blue in the upper panel.
Interestingly, none of the regions spanning these variants exhibited
enhancer activity in the luciferase reporter assay shown in the lower panel graphs,
and accordingly, no variant-specific effects were
observed.Whether these variants might exert regulatory
activity in different contexts or via different mechanisms
would require further studies.
We next investigated the role of STARD13 in BRCA pathogenesis using RNA
sequencing. First, our goal was to identify genes that show a combined
regulatory signature, such as synergistic effect on rescue effects.
From this, we expected to generate a high-confidence list of effector
gene that are central to the dysregulated interaction between
BRCA2 mutation and STARD13.
Second, we focused on constructing regulatory networks and
performing pathway enrichment analysis.
So
this allowed us to determine which biological pathways, metabolic process,
or cell cycle functions are broadly altered by BRCA2 mutation, and
how deletion of STARD13 may either disrupt or partially correct
these alterations.
Before performing RNA sequencing, we first assessed the STARD13 expression at both
the transcript and protein level in wild-type and 6174delT
mutant MCF10A and HMLE cell lines.
Following siRNA-mediated knockdown, as shown in Figure A and C.
Figure B and D show that STARD13 ablation has a stronger effect on
LATAS2 downregulation in the 6174delT mutant
background in both MCF10A and HMLE cell lines.
Prior work by Bristow and co-worker from Switzerland have demonstrated that the
last gene play a key role in regulating the luminal basal phenotype
balance in breast epithelial cells.
In line with this, our study shows that LATAS2 is significantly
downregulated in BRCA2 mutant cells, suggesting a
disruption in this regulatory axis.
Additionally, we identify STARD13 as a potential BRCA2 modifier,
indicating it may contribute to modulating breast cell phenotype in the
context of BRCA2 deficiency. Together, these findings suggest a
coordinated pathway involving LATAS2 and
STARD13 that could influence breast cancer biology in
BRCA2 mutant settings.
We then performed RNA sequencing for gene expression analysis in the
MCF10A cell line. Figure on the left shows the PCA plot, which
demonstrates clear clustering of the samples.
In MCF10A cells, STARD13 showed a statistically
significant difference with a modest fold change in BRCA2
mutant versus wild type background.
This pattern was distinct compared to other candidate genes identified
from the GWAS of BRCA2 modifiers reported by
BRCA2 case-only association. Overall gene expression
analysis in the BRCA2 mutant breast cell model highlights
STARD13 as a strong putative candidate gene.
Preliminary RNA sequencing analysis revealed that genes such as MMP9 and
TSPEN18, which directly or indirectly promote growth
signaling, are upregulated in BRCA2 delT mutant when
STARD13 is attenuated. Broadly, these data suggest that
pathway affecting extracellular matrix, cell stress signaling,
proliferation, and migration are activated in the mutant.
Next, we selected representative genes from luminal, basal, and
mesenchymal pathways and visualized them using a volcano plot.
In the BRCA2 mutant sample shown on the right, we observed a
markedly higher number of significantly regulated genes compared to wild type
group. Many of these genes are involved in luminal-basal-mesenchymal
transitions, indicating enhanced pathway activity and
cellular plasticity in the mutant condition.
This suggests that BRCA2 mutation may drive broader transcriptional
reprogramming linked to breast cancer progression.
Our pathway analysis revealed several breast cancer-relevant programs
associated with STARD13, including EZH2 target gene regulation,
extracellular matrix remodeling, endocrine therapy resistance, and
epithelial-mesenchymal state transitions.
Together, these findings suggest that STARD13 may act as a central
regulator, linking epigenetic control, tumor microenvironment,
and cellular plasticity. This highlights the potential role for
STARD13 in influencing breast cancer progression, invasion,
and treatment response.
In summary, we generated MCF10A cell line harboring BRCA2
6174delT mutation model
and BRCA2-associated genetic alterations in
breast epithelial cells. Using FPS-based prioritization of SNPs,
including RS3742324, along with alpha
genome analysis, we identified key candidate regulatory variants.
Functional validation showed that the RS3742324
genomic region exhibits allele-specific enhancer activity,
supported by both luciferase reporter assays and qPCR analysis.
Thus, we postulate that STARD13 plays a role in regulating the
luminal-basal-mesenchymal transition pathway under condition of
BRCA2 deficiency.
Collectively, these findings suggest that STARD13 is a potential genetic
modifier influencing BRCA2-associated breast cancer risk and
phenotypes.
So before I conclude, I would like to acknowledge the support from our
research team, including its leaders, Dr. Joseph and Dr.
Offit, as well as Mital Waghmare, Jonathan Amsellem,
Krista Kazmierczyk, and Katlyn Jones.
The RNA sequencing was performed at the MSKCC Integrated Genomics Core
Lab. This study was supported by the Andrew Sabine Family
Foundation and the Breast Cancer Research Foundation.
We also acknowledge support from the MSKCC Core Grant for providing
essential infrastructure and resources that made this research
possible. Thank
you.I
can answer if you have some questions.
I think we have time for one question.
Okay.
I have a question.
Do you have any ideas for why
the variants that were prioritized by AlphaGenome were not confirmed by
functional studies? Or maybe comment on the differences between the
FPS algorithm and AlphaGenome?
Yeah. AlphaGenome is a pretty new model, and we wanted to test
that model. So there are three different modalities, how they
test your input. So
there may be some other features which are associated with that.
We don't know yet. So maybe splicing and all those
factors. Although we looked for the open chromatin, so we were expecting
that there should be some enhancer activity, but we didn't find.
So maybe there are other features. We don't know yet.
Yeah. So maybe the mechanisms that you tested were not the ones that-
Yes
... AlphaGenome prioritized.
Yeah.
Okay. That's interesting. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much.
All right.
Well, this concludes our session. I hope all of you enjoyed it.
I know that I certainly learned a lot from all of our presenters.
Just give me one moment here.
Just a quick question. Our team, would it be possible to pull up my slides?
Those were the ones that we had at the start of the session.
Yeah.
There we go.
Okay. Thank you so much.
All right. So I have no financial relationships to disclose.
And so I've tried to summarize this really incredible
breadth and diversity of research that we heard today into some
overarching themes. And so I think we had quite a number of very interesting
presentations that touched on different aspects of cancer
etiology and risk prediction. And I think all of these studies really
highlighted how integrative genomic analyses in
large and well-characterized cohorts or
consortia type pool data sets can really uncover very interesting and
very informative interplay between genetic and environmental risk factors.
So one of the examples was, of course, this proteomic signature of
persistent effects of smoking and how that has potential to
improve risk stratification for lung cancer.
We've also seen very interesting work that shows how this
observational association between taller height and
increased risk of fatal prostate cancer is more likely attributable to
genetic factors rather than dietary factors.
And our other study, which examined this really fascinating
gene-environment interaction between the colorectal cancer PRS
and both cohorts, which again identified some effect
modification that is happening by decade of birth.
And then I also think that there's a lot that we learned today about tumor
biology, and within that, I think
we've had two really fantastic presentations that really showcase the
importance of population diversity
in this line of research. And in particular, focusing
on ovarian cancer, how studying ancestrally,
racially, and ethnically diverse populations can really lead to a lot of
interesting novel insights, both into tumor
subtypes,
signatures of the tumor microenvironment, and can, of course,
identify
and perhaps elucidate the mechanisms that are underlying some of the racial
disparities
for different cancers and for different subtypes.
And then continuing with the theme of insights into tumor biology, I think we'd
also like to highlight some really interesting new studies that highlight these
emerging and novel biomarkers of tumor recurrence as well
as risk modifiers. So the work that we heard on
DTCs, which are associated with distinct somatic and mutagenic features
that could potentially be markers of greater proliferative capacity
and maybe even therapeutic resistance in breast cancer.
And of course, our very last talk, which I think is a really fantastic example
of the importance of doing functional follow-up of a lot of our GWAS loci,
which again, can uncover potential modifiers
of genetic risk and their underlying pathways.
And just to summarize a few future directions, I think these are themes
that all of our speakers touched on, as well as my co-chair,
is that I think that moving forward, the recruitment of
larger and more diverse patient populations and having
these larger, well-characterized studies will obviously continue to be more
important. But I think I would maybe really like to highlight the point
that now that we're moving on to this post-GWAS era of
just having extremely large sample size, I think we also want to be thinking
about the depth of data that we have on the participants, and so
really integrating genomic, multi-omic, epidemiological, and
clinical data on all of these participants, as opposed to just simply
having the largest possible study.
I think we should all feel very inspired by the technological advances and
the high throughput molecular profiling that are now
allowing us to unpack a lot of these
mechanisms. In particular, I think will hopefully allow
us to move to the next stage of not just uncovering population-level
associations, but actually trying to unpack some of the underlying biology a little
bit more.
And lastly, obviously, we're all very excited about AI tools, and
I think they're very powerful, and I think as we generate more and more data, these
tools will continue to become very important, but I think we should always be
skeptical and careful and thoughtful users of these very powerful
algorithms. And of course, this type of work is simply
not possible without collaboration, whether it's large
consortia or collaborations between different groups, bringing together
complementary expertise. For us, as population-based scientists, it's so important
to engage with our colleagues who are more on the functional genomics
side of things to make sure that
we're presenting the type of evidence that really allows them to leverage their
strengths and identify some of the underlying mechanisms.
So with that, I'll conclude our session. Thank you very much.
Great
job.
Thank
you.